function G can be thought of as a scaled
version of f of X is equal to x squared
write the equation for G of X so like
always pause this video and see if you
can do it on your own
alright now let's work through this
together so the first thing that we
might appreciate is that G seems not
only to be flipped over the x-axis but
then flipped over and then stretched
wider so let's do these in steps so
first let's flip over flip over the
x-axis so if we were to do this visually
it would look like this so instead when
X is equal to 0 we'll struggle why is
still going to be equal to 0 but when X
is equal to negative 1 instead of Y
being equal to 1 it now be equal to
negative 1
when X is equal to 1 instead of squaring
one and getting one you then take the
negative of that to get to negative 1 so
when you flip it it looks like this Y
when X is equal to negative 2 instead of
Y being equal to 4 it would now be equal
to negative 4 so it would look like this
so as we just talked through is we're
trying to draw this flipped over version
whatever Y value we were getting before
for a given X we would now get the
opposite of it or the negative of it so
this green function right over here is
going to be y is equal to the negative
of f of X or we could say Y is equal to
negative x squared whatever the X is you
square it and then you take the negative
of it whatever X is you square it and
then you take the negative of it and you
see that that will flip it over the
x-axis but that by itself does not get
us to G of X G of X also seems to be
stretched in the horizontal direction
and so let's think about can we multiply
this times some scaling factor so that
it does that stretching so that we can
match up to G of X and the best way to
do this is to pick a point that we know
sits on G of X and they in fact give us
one they show us right over here that
the point two comma negative one sits on
G of X when X is equal to two Y is equal
to negative
one on G of X so you could say G of 2 is
negative 1 now on our green function
when X is equal to 2 y is equal to
negative 4 so let's see maybe we can
just multiply this by 1/4 to get our G
so let's see if we were to let's see if
we scale by 1/4 do that does that do the
trick
scale by 1/4 so in that case we're going
to have y is equal to not just negative
x squared but negative 1/4 1/4 x squared
and if you're saying hey so how did you
get 1/4 well I looked at when X is equal
to 2 on our green function when X is
equal to 2 I get 2 negative 4 but we
want that 2 when X is equal to 2 to be
equal to negative 1 well negative 1 is
1/4 of negative 4 so that's why I said
okay let's let's just see if we could
take our green function if I multiply it
by 1/4 that seems like it'll be it'll
will match up with G of X and so let's
let's verify that when X is equal to 0
well this is still all going to be equal
to 0 so that makes sense when X is equal
to 1 let me do this in another color
when X is equal to when X is equal to 1
then 1 squared times negative 1/4 well
that does indeed look like negative 1/4
right there when X is equal to 2 2
squared is 4 times negative 1/4 is
indeed equal to negative 1 when let's
try at this point here because it looks
like this is sitting on our graph as
well when X is equal to 4 4 squared is
16 16 times negative 1/4 is indeed equal
to negative 4 and it does work also for
the negative values of X as well so I'm
feeling really good that this is the
equation of G of X G of X is equal to
negative 1/4 times x squared and so in
general that when we're saying we're
scaling it we're scaling it by negative
value this is what flips it over the
x-axis and then multiplying it by this
this just frac
that has an absolute value less than one
this is actually stretching it wider if
this value right over here it's absolute
value was greater than one then it would
stretch it vertically or make it thinner
in the horizontal direction